hello folks welcome to rational science
the only set on the internet that does
physics rationally
and if you please give me a second here
I want to check to see if uh if I'm uh
online
okay I want to see how it looks
hello welcome to rational science the
only stud on the internet that does
physics rationally
and if you please give me a second here
I want to check to see if uh if I'm uh
online
okay I want to see how it looks
hello welcome to rational science
the only stud on the internet that does
physics rationally
and if you please give me a second here
I want to check to see if uh if I'm uh
online
okay I want to see how it looks
hello welcome to rational science
okay folks I hope you can hear me I hope
you can see me I'd like for someone to
confirm that someone said that
everything's okay but I'm with a
different computer and it's driving me
nuts there's a lot of stuff that's
happening with this computer and it's
not working the way I was hoping it
would so please confirm that everything
is okay
yeah I had to I was listening to my own
sound that's why we had double sound but
if you can hear me we should be okay I
just want to make sure I saw one of my
videos it looked like
very bad
okay okay so let's get started here
folks
okay uh let's get started
um I'm gonna skip the um Extinction
segment all I can say about that is
regarding the Ukraine war and that is
that
um a general high high level General
today or yesterday I think it was today
uh said that the war in Ukraine is doing
great you know it's doing great but they
have to speed it up because they only
have one month to go until the bad
weather sets in and it screw-ups all the
pl plans but that's not what interested
me what interested me what I read
between the lines and uh and uh this
General said that uh there was Victory
anyways
and I said Victory anyways what is he
talking about and so the issue was that
it's not a defeat that the Russians
conquered the Eastern provinces of
Ukraine it's a victory
that Russia did not conquer all of
Ukraine
and so that made me think that maybe
they're preparing the world for you know
some bad news that uh if if the the
ukrainians don't succeed against the
Russians uh in in the next month that
means that they're counter-offensive uh
stopped or came to nothing uh then they
might have to sit at a table and
negotiate you know
on both sides you know what they're
going to do all I can tell you is don't
choose sides I learned in my life not
just two sides uh in any of these wars
or whatever and again I put it in these
terms so that you can understand
um do you prefer to go with Bugs Moran
or without Capone who do you think is is
better
and that's more or less the situation
here they're all mafiosi they're all
Mafia you know and each one defends his
own interests and so I don't care it
doesn't doesn't get to me I I'm not
going to choose sides even if they bribe
me with beer Okay so
no go
anyways let's get on with the subject
matter today because I got a a lot of
ground to cover
yeah I look like real built
okay I got a lot of ground to cover
today so we're gonna start with the
etherist why because uh there's some
loose ends that need to be connected I
guess you know tied up and so I'm going
to start there and in order to start
there I need to start with the uh
kindergarten physics because some of
these people have not gone through
kindergarten physics but they want to do
college level physics you know they want
to talk about their theories their great
theories whatever they thought about and
they don't know the basics they don't
know kindergarten what they're supposed
to do you know the kindergarten side
they never played with blocks okay we
need for them to come back to
kindergarten play with blocks and
understand the basics of physics before
they can move on okay so let's start
with the kindergarten method I'm sorry
for those of you who already know all
this stuff you know it's it's probably
boring uh you know but
um I need to cover these loose ends on
the one one hand and it's a refresher
for those who know it okay so here it
goes okay so here we have uh this is
physics uh kindergarten okay we're gonna
be doing this and the first thing you
first rule you have to understand is
that
um what they do today is known as the
mathematical method they've been doing
it for the last 400 years more or less
since the 17th century so-called
Scientific Revolution and this is what
it's all about or what's come down to
today it says the purpose is what to
persuade convince convert and recruit
that's what the whole method is all
about and making money becoming popular
you know hitting the the bright lights
Etc what is the mathematical method well
it consists of observation they observe
You observe something happening you do
an experiment to repeat the observation
more or less this is this is just a
sketch right uh scouting of uh what what
they do you measure especially the
visible objects because you can measure
the invisible ones or untouchable
unseeable right and you describe the
motion that you observed or that you
measured with an equation you propose
the most irrational explanation you can
imagine because that's what they do they
use Concepts as physical objects they
use words such as field and energy and
mass when they should not be using that
for a physical interpretation
and they asked their colleagues to
challenge the you know the um uh the the
findings to confirm the the fellows
findings you know the person who did the
the uh work and then if uh more than 50
of them of your colleagues uh agree with
you then uh it becomes a theory you know
the hunch the speculation suddenly
morphs into a theory and if more than 90
percent believe in it then the theory
becomes a fact and so that's how you end
up with I guess the Flat Earth Society
you know everybody votes for it and and
so it becomes a fact
and then you go on a talk circuit and
win prizes that's the uh mathematical
method that's what we see today out
there okay and so uh we're trying to
contrast against that the scientific
method which none of these people have
discovered in the last 400 years that's
what we do here we do the scientific
method uh as it relates to physics okay
so here it is
uh this is the scientific method okay
um
we the purpose is to explain rationally
okay very straightforward and uh we do
what is called a hypothesis that's the
first step okay of the scientific method
uh the you know people out there who I
call idiots uh idiot is an individual
with Big Ideas there you see the
definition at the bottom uh these people
call it semantics word salad waste of
time you know Etc no no you must do the
hypothesis you have to tell us what your
assumptions are and the assumptions
include the following include the
objects the people the things that are
going to play a relevant role in your
theory okay unless you uh introduce the
objects first we will not understand
your Theory of physics okay so you need
to start with the object you need to
point to them and say look this is a
tree this is a rock this is a stone or a
house or whatever
and you point to them and once you can
get past that step you can go on to your
theory but until you can point to the
objects and Define your terms
scientifically meaning that you are able
to defend your definitions against
attacks okay people are not gonna like
your definitions maybe and so you're
gonna have to be able to defend them so
you need to point to the objects you
need to Define your words in such a way
that you can use them consistently
rationally
scientifically and uh and then you
present the statement of the facts what
we call the initial scene first frames
of the film okay so that we know what
your starting point is you need to point
to that first frame of your film you
can't do it like they do it with big
bang that they start at the second frame
now we need to know how the singularity
came to be and that's the first frame or
you know you need to show that process
and until you got that you don't have a
movie you can't start at the second
frame in the movie and then yes you move
on to the second step which is theory in
other words the explanation of a cause
of a mechanism and finally you end up
with conclusions
okay that's uh that's how we think the
scientific method should be done if you
have any objections well you have to put
them you have to explain why what
objections you have
um you know specify fight it I have no
problem with people fighting it but
that's the scientific method you don't
like it well make your case you know
you're in a court of law okay okay so um
here we have
um the issue with the etherist and uh
you know what we know is that you know
you let go of a uh a spoon for example
right
and it falls to the floor
spoon is made of molecules comprised of
atoms okay so we're just going to look
at one atom of the spoon
and one atom of the earth any atom that
you want you know inside the earth and
for some reason the atom of the spoon is
attracted
you know it's uh absorbed it's pulled
whatever you want to use
by the atom in the center of the earth
you want to use push no problem
something maybe is pushing the atom of
the spoon against the Earth either way
no problem okay but we have to explain
the process the mechanism why does One
Atom approach another atom that's what
we're trying to figure out here okay
that we call that process that
phenomenon we call it gravity you want
to call it x no problem we call it
gravity one atom is attracted to another
atom we have to explain why what caused
that atom to approach the other atom
okay attraction okay that's uh it could
be push no problem but you gotta explain
the process okay that's all we're saying
here okay so here we have two atoms our
two atoms you can say one belongs to the
spoon the other one to the Earth you can
say one atom belongs to whatever a
feather an elephant the other one to uh
the sun I don't care but we have two
atoms One's Gonna approach the other
atom we have to explain what causes one
atom to approach the other atom okay
that's that's the starting point that's
what we have to explain okay and
um and so that's the question okay we
need to find out if there's something in
between there okay perhaps maybe
something on the outside pushing them in
fine yeah you know everybody's got their
own theories okay so that's what we're
going to try to explain okay we got that
uh and I put them sideways but you can
put them up and down in any direction
you want if you want to explain gravity
for example no problem because after all
you know the Earth is is on the ecliptic
of the sun it's on the atoms are on the
same level and you could say they're
sideways you know they're not up and
down or like we are here in Earth you
know towards the center of the Earth
okay so how does quantum mechanics
explain this type of thing well they
they go through light they try to
explain light and how light is
manufactured by the atom okay that's
their starting point and what they do is
uh they try to explain gravity but they
can't okay and you'll see why okay here
it is okay this is their version they
have two atoms the atoms are the
planetary atoms that's what they use
they deny it they constantly deny it but
that's what they use because that's what
they're going to use for ionization
they're going to use it for Quantum jump
and they're going to use add-on for
electricity they're going to talk about
the bead electron bead going from atom
to atom that's their version of
electricity so yeah the even though they
deny bores uh rather right uh Quantum
atom the planetary atom that is exactly
what they're going to be using for their
explanations that's the one we're going
to use here if someone has a different
atom he's got to put it in gender right
so what is it they say that when the
atom when the electron bead goes from
different energy levels back and forth
by doing so it emits and absorbs energy
energy is
um mediated or Illustrated as waves of
light we're creating light
electromagnetic waves okay and as you
can see the waves go outwards okay and
the question is if they go outwards how
does that pull because the atom is
shooting that thing out it does absorb
also but you know uh we don't know if
it's from the same atom that's
um you know that it's trying to attract
okay so all we know is that each atom is
throwing electromagnetic waves called
Energy in every direction radially and
by shooting it out we don't know how
that pulls anything inwards so that's
one problem another problem again is the
atom and then there's another atom and
that's another problem which is the wave
okay and as you can see you see a bunch
of arrows there here let me point that
out a little clearly okay this is what
you're seeing you're seeing what is
known as an electromagnetic wave and
what is an electromagnetic wave well it
consists of vectors and electric Fields
the field is that whole thing for
example one of those the red one the red
group of arrows those are called the
electric field and the blue ones here
are called the magnetic field okay what
is a field made of vectors what is a
vector what is a field well there you
see it at the bottom field is a quantity
okay and what's Vector another quantity
so both of these are mathematical terms
both field and Vector are mathematical
terms they have nothing to do with
physics they're just they're just
descriptions numerical descriptions so
what I'm saying here you cannot use this
uh so-called wave you cannot use the
field you cannot use the vector to give
a physical interpretation to a
phenomenon you cannot use that to say
that gravity is a wave or gravity is a
field or gravity is a vector you cannot
use that that way because these are all
mathematical Concepts they have to do
with measurement and with
um pre-established standards okay so um
we cannot use these Concepts these
abstract Concepts to do if I mean you
can't pull on a donkey with a vector you
cannot pull on a donkey with a field and
you cannot pull on a donkey with wet a
wave now if you want to pull out a
donkey you got to put a rope maybe
around its neck or other or uh I don't
know a tie wrap
pull them in okay okay how do we do it
in science well in science we put a
physical object to explain the physical
mechanism okay that's what we're
interested in here and here you see our
model we're saying look uh we have the
quantum jump no problem but it's a shell
that it's expanding and Contracting
that's what we say the atom looks like
it's a ball okay it's like a balloon
okay I hope that's clear there you have
the 2D model on the left the 3D model on
the right light is torsions of a rope
that connects these two atoms okay and
so as they expand and contract they
torque the Rope that's light and that's
Quantum jump all in one shot what you're
staring at is uh physical entity okay
we're not talking about abstractions
we're not talking about Concepts
mathematical Concepts we're talking
about physical entities we're saying the
electron the I'm sorry the atom hydrogen
atom is a ball okay so there you have
two hydrogen atoms they're pumping back
and forth they're torquing the rope that
interconnects them and here's the
construction of this thing okay you'll
see it here in a second
um the Rope turns into
the threads of the Rope right two
threads of the Rope turned into one goes
through the center of the atom and forms
the proton uh star and the other one
loops around for those since the
electron shell okay the electron
membrane that encapsulates the proton
star okay and there you see more or less
what it looks like you can see the Rope
on one side and the thread the electric
thread going to the center of the atom
okay so this is our model so the atoms
and the Rope are constructed of the same
threads
um there's no difference between them
okay
okay so that's our model and you can see
it's all physical
we're talking about a rope we're talking
about two threads or a rope made of two
threads what's a thread well if you
don't know what a thread is ask your
grandmother for a needle and you know to
sew your uh pants and she'll put a
thread through it and that's a thread
okay so some people say oh thread is a
concept no no a thread is an object okay
uh it looks more or less like this this
is a big thread okay a thick thread but
it would look something like that it's
an elongated object
okay so a thread is a physical object
our threat is three-dimensional very
thin very
um
short very I mean narrow right uh but
it's uh it's 3D okay and so is the Rope
so is the atom so we're talking about
all 3D stuff here we're just saying it's
very thin and just like we can't see
atoms much less can we see the Rope
which is much thinner than you know the
diameter of an atom
okay so here we have um
the electromagnetic wave compared
against the rope and you can see why
they've mistaken it over all these years
it looks pretty much the same way except
that they're talking about Concepts
they're talking about waves fields and
vectors and here we're talking about two
threads and we gave them the same name
electric thread and magnetic thread just
to keep with convention that's the only
reason we use the word electric and
magnetic there's no difference between
the thread except the threads except
that one torques around the other or
twines around it okay but there you see
it and we say that it's a good thing
that we can show that the wave equation
C equals c meaning the speed of light
equals frequency times wavelength that
means when you increase frequency you
reduce the wavelength and vice versa and
to the lower right there you see why
because you take any rope the more you
torque it the shorter the links okay and
the mornings that you can put for a
given a given length of rope okay so uh
we think we're in in a pretty good
ballpark uh what's out there of what
Mother Nature uses out there okay and uh
so here we have back our two atoms okay
and the question is what is an ether is
going to put in there the quantum
mechanics they uh put in their uh wave
Fields vectors right uh those are
Concepts so we don't accept them in
science in physics to give a physical
interpretation uh we put a rope what is
the etheris going to put in there well
uh hopefully they put some ether in
there whatever ether is okay
so let's find out what it is okay so
people say Bill you don't know what the
ether is why because every time they ask
me for The Ether this is what I put up
there That's The Ether bunch of
particles that's what it's always been
nothing different than that okay and uh
these people say no bill You're
misrepresenting The Ether that's not the
ether what can we do with particles okay
no problem uh call it something else but
if you want to use the word ether I'm
not going to object either it doesn't
matter to me but this is what the ether
has always been okay why is it uh
because they've always thought at least
since the 17th century since uh the days
of Robert Hook who was the guy who
discovered that light has wave
properties uh this is what they thought
of it at least in the 19th century they
thought that The Ether the bunch of
particles uh where what the light was
made of all these um you know um you can
say the electromagnetic wave was made of
particles what else was it made of I
mean what is a wave other than vectors
it's either vectors or particles
physically they were thinking of
particles okay and uh of course uh you
had Michaelson and Morley uh they ran a
couple experience series of experiments
really uh to try to show whether the
ether existed or not and to their
satisfaction or through a lot of
mathematicians of those days uh
researchers They concluded there is no
ether why did they conclude that because
you know they they looked at the ethers
an ocean of particles and they said well
look the Earth is moving against the
ocean of particles against this ocean
like a fish moves against an ocean or
like the Higgs Bozo you know the ahig's
field
uh what is that a bunch of particles and
a fish is moving against that the little
particle fish right and some go swiftly
through and some go slower that's that's
pigs in a nutshell that's what they
claim to have proven for Mass okay great
and uh The Ether was more or less the
same thing you had the Earth moving in
this ocean called ether bunch of
particles and of course there should be
a difference if you move against
you know the particles then if you move
you know in a different direction with
respect to the particles okay and what
they show to their satisfaction at least
is that light does not change its speed
whether it goes against or sideways or
in any direction and Einstein came a few
years later and he said look uh I think
I've I figured it out light travels are
the same speed all the time irrespective
of the movement of the source of that
light
okay and he was totally right the only
problem is that Einstein couldn't
explain why that was the case how can
you explain that physically
mathematically you know they just wrote
an equation how do you prove that or how
do you how do you uh explain that how do
you explain that mechanism from a
physical point of view and yeah I've
showed that the other day so I'm not
going to go through that again but yeah
we can explain that very easily with a
rope model the ropes the atoms simply
slide through the rope and that's why it
doesn't add to the speed of light the
torsion of the Rope between two atoms
okay that's in a nutshell okay so um
so uh where did I get all this uh well
one fellow asked that question he said
the following he says when was The Ether
declared to be particles in history
and my answer is uh Greeks you know the
ether was air and arrow everybody
thought of era's particles
you know even to this day what do you
think of uh air uh when somebody says
you're breathing air well you're
breathing a lot of molecules and each
molecule is made of atoms right and
there's all kinds of garbage in the air
so you're breathing all those particles
what is the air air is particles and
that's what the ether was The Ether was
the heir of the Gods the particles that
the gods breathe that's more or less
than the notion uh it has your own
threads robes accurately describe the
properties of ether
no no uh our threats have nothing at all
to do with a bunch of particles which is
what the ether was so if you're gonna
talk about the threads in terms of ether
we're going to use the notion that
everybody understands by Ether except
the ethers okay the ethers are the only
people who don't know what the ether is
but everybody out there knows what the
ether is it's a bunch of particles and
no the threads are not made of discrete
particles the thread is made of a single
piece it's a flexible single piece
thread that builds all the atoms and all
the ropes that interconnect the atoms in
the universe okay so uh no the has
nothing to do with the ether at all
okay so um where did we get this well we
got it from this fellow or one one of
these fellas uh this is Aristotle there
he's on the left if you don't see him
down there at the bottom and um and yeah
this is what they thought they thought
that the Greeks they thought that The
Ether was uh this air that the god
breathed out there in the dark night you
know they couldn't see it and they say
yeah but there's something out there and
so they said what covers everything here
on Earth well it's The Ether so The
Ether somehow became you know this
Universal uh
body of particles that the gods breathe
up there in the Olympus okay Mount
Olympus so that's more or less the
notion where it came from and people say
Billy you're full of it
okay so let's uh prove it to them let's
prove they want proof they want evidence
okay let's do that let's do a little
proof of evidence here it is from the
Wikipedia for I'm sorry from
dictionary.com first ether the ancient
Greek what personification of clear
upper air of the sky what was it a bunch
of particles that's what it was that's
what they thought of it uh here's a
mythological origins in the Wikipedia
says the word ether you know in the
homeric Greek means pure fresh air or a
clear sky okay and uh it was thought to
be pure essence of the uh that the gods
breathe filling the space where they
lived analogous to what the air breathes
by Mortals so ether means air okay and
air is made out of particles so they
thought of air of the ethers many
particles and there's another comment
there in the Fifth Element in that same
article for The Ether it says speaking
about air
but is it air right Plato mentions that
there is the most translucent kind which
is called the name of ether
okay so what is ether ether means air
okay it's just another word for air and
uh air is made out of particles
so there you have it very simple
straightforward all those people who
call themselves etherists and they say
it's not a bunch of particles then they
don't know what the ether is The Ether
has always been a bunch of particles
that's the definition of that concept
it's not a physical object okay A a
bunch of particles does not an object
make the uh what makes an object is
shape you point to the table and you're
not pointing to every atom that makes
the table you're pointing to the whole
thing the whole shebang and card table
same with the rock same with the tree
that's the way you got to look at The
Ether the ether's the whole shebang
and if you want to talk about a portion
of what it's made out of you know
myriology that's got nothing to do with
physics that's got to do with her
religion known as myriology okay it's
got to do with what philosophers do
which has nothing to do with physics
they call themselves philosophers
okay
um one fellow says okay here he is he
says uh I never said The Ether was an
object okay
uh it's a physical substance nonetheless
see the word substance in the word
object are perfect synonyms there's no
difference between them in physics now
we're not talking about ordinary speech
over there in ordinary speech they have
all these words and there's nuances in
the definitions in uh physics it's black
or white it's either half shape or a
dumped just that simple so uh the word
object the word substance thing body uh
entity you know all those are synonyms
synonyms perfect synonyms no difference
between them okay so he can't say it's
uh not an object but it's a substance no
not in physics in physics substance and
object means exactly the same thing so
obviously he hasn't gone through
kindergarten physics and he doesn't
understand that okay so of course it has
no shape
well if it has no shape it's a concept
it's black or white it either has shape
and it's an object or it don't have
shape and it's a concept okay you can't
see its shape but if it it don't have
shape then then you can't see it
obviously you know you can't see its
shape meaning it does have shape but you
just can't see it I mean what's the
issue here okay so this is where we have
a little bit of contradiction a lot of
people make this contradiction that's
why I'm putting what this all said up
here because it's uh it's kind of
didactic tool for all those you know to
use against all those people who watch
for The Ether and they don't even know
what they're saying okay so he says the
shape is defined by a container meaning
it does have shape because you can shape
it you can mold it to whatever you want
and that's uh absolutely uh wrong
anyways okay it's not true okay but he
he thinks it true he thinks that water
has shape only because it's in the glass
container in your cup or whatever okay
not true okay water had shape before you
put it in your in your container it's
like any other type of fluid like space
Oh space is a fluid yeah and he says
that space and ether have the same thing
so this is one of those files who says
space and ether the same thing other
ether is say no space contains ether
like if ether was a bunch of particles
that are put into a container called
space so they have these differences as
well you gotta find you know all these
ethers they don't agree they should have
a powwow and resolve their differences
before coming here
it takes on the shape contain containing
it again he thinks uh he uh you know a
bunch of particles I mean a bunch of
molecules a bunch of atoms uh they don't
have shape on their own without
something constraining them this is
their notion okay they have the
squeezing this pressure idea in their
minds that you need to contain somehow
the particles in order for them to have
shape and no anything made out of atoms
an atom has shape anything made out of
atoms had better have shape
whether there's a container or not it
already has saved before you put it in
the container and they don't understand
anything made out of atoms had better
have shape ether has the shape of the
Universe I love that one okay what is
the shape of the universe please draw
the universe so we know what what the
shape of ether is so he constantly
contradicts himself on the one hand he
says it doesn't have shape then it says
the shape of the container has the shape
of the universe and all we want is for
him to draw a picture of the universe of
the container or whatever you know we
need a picture of The Ether okay and he
says does air have shape does water have
shade no they don't
oh my God so again this poor fellow has
never gone through kindergarten physics
uh and but he he has strong ideas about
the ether okay so let's show him that
yes absolutely air does have shape and
water does have shape or liquid any
liquid any fluid for that matter has
shape anything made out of atoms have
shape let's illustrate that Forum here
we have an astronaut and he's going to
pinch he's going to pop a balloon
in the middle of space and that balloon
contains some air
or whatever gas you want I mean as long
as we can color code it so that we can
take a snapshot of it and I want you to
tell me if you see some kind of shape
floating in space here okay here it goes
okay
that's the air that the foul release
here you're going to see how he pops the
balloon okay
okay he's gonna pop the balloon okay and
the air comes out does that blob of air
does that have shape does it have a
container
I mean it's in the middle of space I
don't know what container you think it
has
okay now you know uh you may not like uh
to think that their particles can be
without a container but you have the air
on Earth the air on Earth covers our
planet because of gravity some something
we call gravity a process a phenomenon
we call gravity and you know that ear
does not leave the planet it just stays
all around the earth for those who
believe in the round earth okay and the
spherical Earth
um that ear has nothing on the outside
pushing it in and the question is why
doesn't the air that's covering the
Earth all that atmosphere why does it
just leave and go to another planet
that's what you got to answer and same
here you can see that the balloon popped
all that air came out if you could take
a snapshot of that okay you would say
that thing that whole blob has shape
blobs have all better have shape
and people say well but it changes from
one moment to the other changes its
shape
we're not talking about the whole movie
we're talking about one frame in the
film just one frame in the Universal
room film does that is there something
in that frame that you can point to
and if you can we call that air that air
that bunch of molecules together the
whole blob we call that shape it's got
shape
okay so yes all liquids all fluids all
have shape okay it's Concepts that don't
have shape okay like plasma plasma
doesn't have shape because plasma cannot
stand still you know you can't take a
snapshot of plasma because what you have
is gas
okay so here you have
um the same astronaut he releases a blob
of some liquid
does that liquid that blob have shape
and hopefully you say that it does okay
and so if you say that it doesn't then
you've got to see an ophthalmologist you
got problems with your eyes
okay so here we have
um this one he says the following says
I'm saying the ether is a continuous
fluid
yeah fluid is a concept you're just
seeing what The Ether does you're not
saying what the ether is
okay so to say it's a fluid it's like
saying what is this fluid oil is fluid
molasses is fluid great and what have
you said
yeah they're fluids they're uh you know
they're liquids
semi-liquids or whatever
uh you haven't said what molasses is you
cannot you haven't distinguished
molasses from oil from water that's the
issue we need to for you to put ether
there next to those and say this is The
Ether and that's how it's different than
molasses otherwise I'm going to say that
your ether is molasses I have all the
right in the world because
um you're saying it's just a fluid it's
a liquid it's a flows
that you just telling me what it does
and so does molasses so I can put
molasses and say okay so you're saying
the ether is molasses how does that pull
on anything or how does that cause
gravity
okay so I can I I'm in my right and
until you can fix that until you can
show us a picture of your ether we won't
know what you're talking about okay it
says a substance such as a liquid or gas
that can flow and again it says a
substance the first thing is a substance
is an object there's a thing in physics
they're all the same words okay
something thing object substance body
they all mean the same thing in physics
it either has shape or a dump if it
don't it's a concept that's that's
simple okay so if it's a substance don't
tell me that ether is not an object you
can't have it both ways you can't say
it's an object but it ain't
okay this is what they do they go back
and forth because they haven't taken
kindergarten physics they say oh you're
talking semantics Bill you're doing word
salad there's absolutely no reason why
the ether can't be fluid okay no problem
we're not criticizing that we're saying
draw it make a picture of it so we know
what you're talking about okay remember
what was the first step object you need
to present the objects the actors in
your theory hopefully you'll have a
theory of physics has actors
you can't say I'm going to do physics
with nothing with absolutely nothing
so so what are we staring at or what
process what what mechanism what what
event what phenomenon what's happening
if there's no object
so the first word you need to Define in
physics is the word object you need to
know what an object is because physics
cannot be done without objects
see how simple it is
and it says if you absolutely insist I
will draw you a blob of ether yeah
try it please
but he didn't do it so I had to do that
okay so what can I say and the only
thing I want to comment here is that
yeah uh I put out there that fluid is
made out of
um I mean the types of fluids that we
know about gas or liquids and both of
them are made out of atoms okay so if
he's gonna say that the ether is made
out of atoms
uh okay you know then then we can talk
about fluids but he's uh hopefully he
won't say that he won't say that ether
is made out of Adam because he wants to
say it the other way around he says that
atoms are made of ether okay so then we
need to find out what this ether is that
he says is a fluid because
um fluids are all made out of atoms that
we know of and so he's got to redefine
the word fluid
and he says something that flows yeah
but the something that flows is made out
of atoms so you can't just say something
that flows because so far he just he
hasn't mentioned what is the actor in
his theory he's just saying I'm going to
consider it like a liquid or a gas or a
water or whatever
and he wants to continue and say let me
tell you my theory no we don't want to
hear your stupid theory if you can
present
if you cannot present your actor you
have no Theory yeah you have nothing to
explain you have no physics
you need that actor what you call word
salad uh semantics we need a lot of that
we need 150 of that okay so put a
picture there so we know what you're
talking about and that we know what's
moving on the screen or we can visualize
it or whatever
okay so here we have our astronaut
releasing The Blob again okay and what
we did the other day we froze that okay
and uh you can see it uh well you can
see it bigger here and here we froze it
I think it's this one uh well yeah you
can have the blob in different shapes
that's all I want to show here you know
you the blob can be a very neat one like
this one okay or you can have this uh
irregular blob here so it doesn't matter
what blob you have the question is does
that blob have shape and someone might
say well it's changing its shape yeah we
don't care
it doesn't have it's a question of
yes or no does it have shape okay and
people think that because it changes its
shape from one moment to the next this
is the notion they have it's not an
object it's not it doesn't have shape or
because it has an irregular shape it
they say it's shapeless that's the
notion of ordinary speech you can't use
that in physics in physics it either has
shape or a dome
black or white
okay and hopefully that blob head shape
okay
okay so what do we do with that blob
well we're trying to see if we can
explain gravity with The Ether
especially gravity okay we can explain
light as well no problem but above all
try to explain gravity because that's
what people have been searching for
you get that well you become famous so
here we have our spoon I talked about
the other day okay it's going to fall to
the ground okay now there's only two
possibilities as far as I'm concerned
one is that you know the blob of ether
pushes on it okay that's one uh scenario
and I don't want to put words in
anybody's mouth okay here's uh the other
scenario The Blob pulls on it from below
somehow okay that's the other notion and
uh so you have to explain whether the
blob pushes or pulls on the on the spoon
because you know that's what we observe
every day you know here uh
you know you let go of the spoon and it
falls to the ground so what we have to
explain is what we call gravity which is
that process you just observed of the
spoon always it never falls to the
ceiling you know it always falls to the
ground
so we just want you to explain why it
falls to the ground is the blob pushing
on the spoon or is it pulling From Below
what does this follow's answer well he
says the following
he says it it is it either one it ain't
either one there is no pull it's
irrational it's not push either okay no
push or pull there's no other form of
contact a physical contact we know about
but he says neither push nor pull so
what is it it's he says it's entrainment
in the flow of ether okay it only Flows
In The Presence of matter otherwise
ether is inertial so simple
yeah okay so let's go with the first
problem entrainment what is entrainment
well when you get carried by the river
it's called entrainment
and the question is why does the river
push you
I mean the river is pushing you all
these molecules but this guy doesn't
understand that he doesn't understand
basic things like you know that a little
five-year-old could understand which is
you know playing with blocks in
kindergarten he doesn't understand
kindergarten visits entrainment is push
you're being taken and he mentions a
Venturi effect which is the same why
does a particle move from one uh
container or whatever to another that's
what you got to explain what causes what
brings it out but pushes or pulls on it
because something is in contact with a
molecule otherwise you're using spirits
and ghosts to explain that process and
they say it's a Venturi effect yeah it's
just sucked out
sucked out by what what is in contact
with a molecule pulling on it or pushing
on it
there's got to be some physical contact
there's only two forms that we know one
is pushing the other one's pull for
something to move right
otherwise it's known as uh you know a
tug of war that nobody wins but uh so
entrainment is push
and either there's no push
he doesn't understand Squad he doesn't
understand what he's saying but a lot of
people think like him and they say oh
there's no boys it's entrainment it's a
maturity effect or whatever okay and the
other problem is he says ether is
inertial
uh you know unless it flows in the
presence of matter it's inertial okay so
please draw The inertial Ether that's
what we want we want to see a total
picture all around the shape of The
Ether
okay at the blob you know whatever you
think the ether is a river whatever it
is I don't care but draw it we want a
picture and it's very simple I I I'm
gonna put the two atoms here you know
that you saw a minute ago or two
particles or whatever
and I want you to put and you can take a
snapshot of that or download the picture
or whatever you have to do uh you know
with uh with your computer and all you
have to do is in that same picture put
whatever the ether is between the two
particles
now that's as easy as it get I mean I
put a rope between two particles quantum
mechanics puts these waves sometimes
they put particles okay no problem
what are you going to put between the
two particles that's what we need to see
and we want a picture we don't want blah
blah blah we don't want words we don't
want explanations we want a picture
I don't know how difficult that can be
I'm going to give you the picture of two
balls which uh you can put cubes if you
want but I put two balls in there and I
call them atoms okay and I want you to
tell me what you're going to put between
the two atoms and the fellow says that
it's The Ether and so I you know he's
got to put the ether between the two
atoms he's got to show us what he's
talking about
okay and that's the issue and it's got
to be all around we need to see the The
Ether all around okay you can't just say
well that extends to the end of the
universe you know and I don't know what
it looks like you know you can't use it
we don't care what it looks like in
reality we want to know what's in your
mind we want you to pull your piece of
your mind out put it out here so that we
can all visualize the same thing that's
going through your brain
hey I hope that's clear I don't know how
how much more clear I can do this right
another fellow comes over and he says
the phone he says nothing is pulling or
pushing when something is falling Bill
gravity is not pushing or pulling ah
okay so I wonder what form of contact
this fellow has going to his uh his head
you know okay maybe you learn something
new he says um
uh gravity is not pushing or pulling it
is accelerating
accelerating okay just because it wants
to it just suddenly decided to
accelerate I mean when you accelerate
your car you're at least pushing on on
something I think you know the
accelerator
uh but he says no here we we do
acceleration without any uh Force
without anything
and to push or pull something requires
force and gravity is not the is the
opposite of force whatever that is okay
he should have put the word so we knew
what he was talking about but there you
have it here you have the equation Force
equals mass times what acceleration that
means that acceleration is equal to what
force force right divided by mass it's
not horse it's Force okay so
acceleration does involve force uh so
again all these people need to take uh
kindergarten physics okay they've never
gone through kindergarten and they want
to do college physics
yeah acceleration requires Force
something to push uh whereas Newton's uh
one of Newton's uh motion laws says that
uh something continues in its uh
straight path unless something else you
know deviates it from that path okay so
you need Force you need contact you need
push or pull but you need something
there and again you can't use really the
word Force you need to put a physical
object there and there has to be
physical contact now a rope contacts an
atom so I have a contact there but
quantum mechanics work with particles
against particles no problem because you
can explain push but what Quantum cannot
explain and will never explain is pull
that's why they're still researching
you cannot produce the the only force
that half of the forces in the universe
which is the force of pool
okay so here we have our uh ether blob
uh other possibility one was a little
blob pushing from above the other one
pulling from below here we have The
Ether that blob that's in the background
well imagine that's the uh inertial
ether that he called you know the static
uh ether so I froze it there and it
covers the universe it goes all the way
to the edge of the universe and what
he's got to explain with that ocean with
a whole ocean he can't take a little
piece of it and try to explain this he's
got to take the whole ocean because
ether is the whole ocean if he's going
to talk about something happening
locally he's got to use a different word
okay and there you see it the spoons are
falling went from one side of the planet
the other one from below they both go in
the opposite directions he got
explaining with his ether how this
phenomenon happened how it is that one
uh spoon goes in the opposite direction
as the other and both fall to the Center
of the Earth so this this is what he's
got to reproduce with his ether and
ether he can put it in motion if he
wants I don't care but he's got to
explain how that happens and again he
can't use a portion of the ether okay
because this is again like um
you have the ocean
and something's happening to one fish in
one localized area of the ocean
you cannot say the ocean pushed the fish
downwards
you can't do that something else
happened because it didn't pull push the
boat or something else that was in the
ocean just pushed that little fellow
that little fish downwards if that
happens it can't be you can't see the
ocean did it the ocean is the whole
thing the whole shebang
you got to say look a little piece of
the ocean and now we have to talk about
that little piece what are you going to
call it what is it you know now we're
talking about something else forget
about the ocean now so you can't use the
word ether to produce that effect now
you have to use uh whatever you want to
call it in the case of the ocean you say
look a little bit of water
there was a Whirlpool or a current or
something affected the fish okay fine
but now you're talking about you know
some water locally water is a physical
object it's a fluid right it's made out
of amount of atoms out of uh molecules
right so water is a physical object it's
a thing that's why it came in contact
with a fish and pushed it down or pulled
it downwards whatever so you can explain
it with water not with the ocean you
can't say the ocean did it and that's
what you're doing when you say The Ether
did it
okay so let's understand ether's the
ocean otherwise we gotta look with at
the what I just showed a minute ago
which is one little blob of ether
pushing uh the spoon downwards or
another one pulling from below and you
gotta explain that process you gotta
show us how The Ether did either one and
yeah you can only use pull and push but
he says he doesn't believe in pull and
push he says it's entrainment which is
push but he doesn't understand that
either he doesn't understand what the
Venturi effect is or how it happened
what causes the Venturi effect to happen
I mean I worked with vacuum many years
and uh vacuum Chambers and you know we
have vacuum pumps uh they're known as
um the the roughing pump the mechanical
pump the rotary vein pump is so so known
you have this little paddle that goes
around inside the the pump and it just
uh takes uh molecules from the chamber
right and that drift in that direction
and it takes it out and then the next
pedal takes another group of atoms out
another group another group of molecules
Etc and in this this way it uh sucks air
and water and other garbage that you
have in the chamber it sucks them out of
the chamber and creates a uh vacuum not
a total vacuum but it it makes a greater
vacuum uh ruffy pumps go to 10 to the
minus three tour uh and then you can
take a cryo pump or a diffusion pump and
pump it down to minus seven which is a
range where we worked with the question
is this is the million dollar question
why does the particle go in that
direction what's drawing it in that
direction
in other words why does uh why do
particles move from a area of great
density to an area of lower density or a
vacuum that's what you got to explain
and people say it does it does so it is
so yeah yeah we know it is so that it
happens you have to explain the cause
the mechanism what is in contact with a
molecule is is there someone Whispering
the molecules here and say go that way
why does a molecule what causes what
physical cause forces the particle to go
to the region of lower vacuum that's
what you got to explain
and people say it does so it is so yeah
we know don't tell me it is so tell me
how how come it is so
and if you cannot explain to how come
don't talk to me about the Venturi
effect or about all the other nonsense
that you get in your head okay because
it means you don't you haven't gone to
kindergarten physics okay okay here we
have another fellow another same fellow
the first one right and he says uh he he
backtracked and he said these are being
a bunch of particles that's your opinion
okay so it ain't a bunch of particles I
don't care for what they thought
hundreds of years ago okay so he doesn't
care about Aristotle the Greeks or 19th
century said what's in between atoms
yeah that's what we're asking and he
says it's The Ether okay so now we had
two atoms which I showed and I want him
to put the ether the static ether The
inertial Ether whatever he wants to call
it so that we can see a picture of The
Ether how else would they attract or
repel each other exactly so show us the
ether show us how The Ether does it and
it says I can't point to magnetism but
it's there yeah you can't point because
you can't see or or or um or field it
with your hands and you're saying it's
there yeah but what is it that it's
there that's what you got to identify
the invisible object that is in that
region we call magnetic field right and
same thing for The Ether it says I can't
point you to Ether it's invisible it's
got nothing to do with visibility or
with tangibility it's got to do with the
ether having shape or not shape and we
need to know what shape you're thinking
about what shape you're visualizing and
I want you to make it visible for all of
us so that we can follow your train of
thought see how simple it is so yeah it
is simple but you're not doing the
simple stuff and yes ether is space okay
so he's saying it's it's the same thing
as space as for the ether blob it was a
joke okay so I explained it with a blob
but now he's backtracking after I call
this Bluff and he says look it was just
I was just joking okay no problem and
I'm saying he's not joking he's really
not joking because of love is what he
described he says it's a fluid
um that is Flowing uh flowing fluid you
know float flu okay so we have a flow
flu that's what we'll call his ether and
we need for him to illustrate the flow
flow okay so uh he can't he he was
talking about a blob a river is a blob
an ocean isn't a blonde so is the air
that covers the earth all those are
blobs so he if he says the blob the The
Ether is fluid and it flows he's talking
about a blob so he was not joking he the
joke's on him or the yolks in his face
whatever
uh it's fluid yeah if it's fluid it's a
blob Dynamics Magneto whatever it says
any substance that flows is considered a
fluid fluid okay great I've been working
on this for many years
I won't go through the entire process
you would let me to my conclusion
uh on the one hand I feel sorry for the
guy because uh I'm sure he has been
working on it for a long time but he
hasn't taken care of the basics he said
he hasn't taken care of the ABCs he
hasn't done kindergarten physics
kindergarten physics identify the option
you need to do that and he never did he
just said oh it's ether and he didn't
use the ether of the Greeks or the 19th
century all the way to the 19th century
which is a bunch of particles he's got
some other Theory and or some other
vision of what the ether is in his head
no problem he wants to use the word
ether to refer to his blob no problem
but it's a blob because he's talking
about a fluid
and that means the blue fluid stops
somewhere
somewhere it's got an end otherwise it's
not an object you can't have an an uh
Eternal or constantly flowing fluid that
uh comes out of nowhere
okay it's got to have total shape we got
to see the whole shebang I want you to
draw the ocean
that's what we need we need the whole
ocean
okay so if you say uh ether is the same
thing as space it extends to the edge of
the universe draw the universe for us
don't tell me don't leave that hanging
out there you know loose hands saying uh
I don't know where it ends and I can't
see it and I can't touch it no no that
that doesn't count in physics in physics
you have to present the objects so that
we can see the uh process the mechanism
that you propose for gravity or how
particle attracts another whatever you
want to call entrainment okay and it
trains okay so and train it show us how
how the mechanism of entrainment that's
what we need to see in detail in detail
but before that you need to illustrate
your ether because otherwise we will not
understand and I'm going to put the two
atoms there for you to put your ether
between them so you know the uh the uh
ball is in your court
and uh yeah what this fellow said
reminds me of something I read the other
day and here he'll probably relate to
this very easily and so will everybody
out there and here it is said uh this
article came out in space.com we still
don't know what dark matter is but
here's what it's not okay and this is
what they say irrelevant part even
though scientists are certain that dark
matter exists
as all our universe's normal matters
simply can't account for the Way
galaxies are kind of held together they
don't know what it is they also don't
really know what who know where it is
though they have some ideas and they
definitely don't know what it looks like
and that's what this guy is saying he's
saying look uh The Ether is there I know
it's there I've seen it I've touched it
I pointed to it where he said it doesn't
have shame I can't see it I can't touch
it I can't you know point to it and he's
saying the same thing as these people
say oh we can't account for dark matter
because we can't see it and uh we can't
smell it and we can't hear it and so
they they go with all these excuses but
they know it's there it exists
so this is the way all these people work
and no that's why we say look that
doesn't work that way in science the way
it works in science is the other way
around you tell me what the dark matter
is then you can talk about it but don't
say it's there we know we've proved it
it's there there's no other possibility
and we're not going to allow any
criticism and let me explain to you my
theory no no it doesn't work that way in
science and science it works the other
way okay you got to point to the dark
matter and then say look with this dark
matter now I can explain you know how a
Galaxy rotates or why the stars don't
fly away or whatever okay that's the way
it works and you got to make whatever's
in your mind visible so that we can
follow your train of thought they don't
do that what do they do they talk about
mass and gravity they use Concepts
they talk about field
energy
we don't want to hear those words we
want to see objects I want to see a dog
I want to see a cat I want to see a rock
I want to see a tree I want to see
something I need to see the physical
interaction between objects things
that's physics but to say that the mass
stated oh you know I mean how did it do
it the the mass the concept Mass pulls
or push how did it do it and so this is
a problem they use concept and this was
doing the same thing with ether he's
saying uh I can't see it I can't touch
it so I can't draw it no no tell me what
you have in your mind I don't care what
the ether is in reality I want you to
draw The Ether that you have in your
mind and show me how it is between two
atoms and very simple stuff really
okay so here we have our two atoms again
okay
and what I'm going to ask him is to put
the uh ether that he's got in his brain
in between those two atoms instead of
that question mark that's what he's got
to do very simple you have two atoms
okay he wants to put cubic atoms
triangular atoms I don't care you can
put whatever Adam I put two balls okay
what appears to be two balls okay so all
he's got to do is put the ether between
them he says the ether is between two
atoms I need to see it between them and
if he says the either extends to the
edge of the universe he's talking about
an ocean and not about what attracts one
uh atom to another which is what he's
got to explain so then he's gotta figure
out you know how he's gonna do this okay
so since C hasn't done so uh I tried to
do it for him he says uh it's a uh flow
flu okay so here we have the flow flu
and we have the uh ether flowing from
one atom to another okay so uh we have
the flow flu we'll call it that's what
we'll call it the ether is the black
stuff that extends all the way to the
edge of the universe no problem but the
flow flu is different than the ether or
it's a portion of the ether or he's got
to explain what that flow flu is and you
can see it's flowing I put a rib right I
even put the fishies in there for them
so I mean you know if you can't
understand this I don't know so you can
see uh the River or the slow flu is
Flowing from one atom to the other how
does that produce attraction how does
that get the two atoms to come together
because if it's flowing it's flowing in
One Direction and One Direction only
okay
and so uh so there you have it uh that's
what he's got to do now I I put another
type of flow flu and this is my flow
through the one that I proposed for him
and that's uh a spirit a ghost you know
I'm one of Casper's friends
and uh he might say well you're making
fun of my theory no I'm not I'm I'm
illustrating what you describe I have
something which is uh fluid okay it's
called a ghost it's called a spirit an
angel whatever you want to call that and
you can see how it's flowing so you have
your flow flu there okay so don't tell
me that I'm making fun of your theory
I'm illustrating what you failed to do
you know like my flow flu my ether then
you put yours in there and show us how
one atom attracts another with your flow
flow okay so that's what you got to do
very simple stuff and it's uh here you
see it okay you know that's what you got
to do you got to point to The Ether
said it several times I need for you to
point to these or put a picture there
right you know between the two atoms you
say The Ether is between two atoms we
want to see it I want to see what you're
talking about okay and if you can't then
that means you haven't imagined your
ether you're just talking you know out
of a because of air is free
okay so here we have uh
okay I see what give me a second here
uh here we have kindergarten physics
again
um so we have the scientific method
what's the first thing he's got to do
he's got to present the objects he
hasn't gotten past that step he hasn't
presented the object yet he wants to
jump all the way to theory he wants to
cause his theory and we don't care about
his theory uh until he can present the
object because if he cannot present the
objects he if he cannot point to them
his theory is bunk it's garbage it's
worthless
so we don't care about his theory okay
we need the objects then he can move on
to his theory okay
and uh here we have another fellow and
he uh butted in he wanted to talk about
The Ether his ether okay and this fellow
says that the ether is two particles
okay he says I have a hypothesis that
can logically explain what could be
referred to as the ether hey great my
hypothesis is that everything that
exists in the universe is composed of
just two incredibly small monopole
particles okay these particles are what
is referred to as the ether okay so
there you have it folks you always
wanted to know what the ether is there
you have it two particles
uh one is negatively charged whatever
that is the second particle is
positively charged whatever that is okay
we don't care about negative or positive
because that's garbage it's nonsense
papika okay uh they don't belong to
physics we don't know what negative or
positive mean in physics there is no
definition no no object that is that you
can say oh that one's negative unless
you're talking about women and men say
women are all negative men are all
positive
here my work will kill me tonight there
exists a massive excess of the negative
particles great that's a description
yeah you haven't explained anything with
that and accounts were the force of
gravity okay great uh you have to show
us the mechanism okay and again what's
the problem here the problem is you
cannot say That's The Ether
because two particles do not an object
make there we have two objects okay two
balls okay so you gotta explain it with
one ball okay you can't explain it with
two balls but uh if you need two balls
to explain your theory no problem you
present one say like this is the red
ball this one's the blue ball you want
to make them green and yellow positive
and negative whatever that means we
don't care we have two balls
take a basketball you take a snowball if
you want okay and then show us how one
snowball or one ball or One tennis ball
or baseball attracts another
that's all you gotta show pull we want
to see the with the force of attraction
how you explain attraction especially
okay that's all you got to do show us
your two particles show us how they're
attracted by this ether or whatever you
know so don't use positive negatives
don't use the word field the word energy
the word mass none of that counts we
need physical objects we just need a
movie of how one particle attracts
another
very simple we want mechanisms and I
don't have that sunk in okay another
person comes in and says what ether is
electric resulting of rotating magnetic
field
well the problem is field is a concept
and Concepts don't rotate so that's the
end of that one
so I don't know what this person drank
okay but um
says that a field rotates no Fields
don't rotate because field is concept
love doesn't rotate you know love
doesn't attract either it can't do it
with love I tried pulling on a horse
with love it didn't work he kicked me
okay and then uh we had a uh people here
who were working on the word object and
I said object is out which has shape and
these people got all hung up on shape so
I had to you know correct them and I did
that last week but the file didn't come
back with any criticism or or analysis
or challenge or anything so I guess
either he accepted
what I uh proposed or had no no counter
arguments in just you know went to the
deck okay so here it is uh he raised the
issue shape is 2D and form is 3D
um object is a collection of matter and
magnetic field has shaped those were
three of the points he made the main
ones and these were my answers that he
failed to address other languages only
have the word form they don't use the
word shape okay the word shape is
primarily English maybe uniquely English
all other languages just use the word
form and you can see why because even in
English shape is a synonym of form okay
and here you can see the uh definition I
presented that the other day of both
shape and form and you can see that
they're perfect synonyms there is no
difference between shape and form form
does not refer to 3D shape does not
refer to 2D okay this is a misconception
that people have out there that's just
uh ordinary speech that people come up
with these Notions that's not true in
the definitions in the dictionary even
if that were important which it ain't
okay but you can see shape the quality
of a distinct object or body and having
an external surface surface is a 3D
concept and so we're talking about shape
has to do with 3D or outline or form
what outline a form or figure okay this
quality is found in some object or body
form outline silhouette Etc and what is
form external appearance of a clearly
defined area areas wet 2D right as
distinguished from color material Etc
okay the shape of a thing or person
okay something that gives or determines
shape okay so you can see that shape and
form are perfect synonyms even in
English but in other languages they
don't have the word
um
shape they only have the word form so
yeah this uh poorer fellow you know he
uh didn't come back he didn't answer the
questions and so I guess he agreed or or
just uh ran away or whatever as an it
didn't address the issues that were
raised okay and just in case here's
another fellow and he made the same
error more or less as a shadow of a ball
has shape
no Shadows don't have shape
that's an ordinary speech okay and yes
people haven't taken kindergarten
physics the ball itself has formed okay
uh does the shadow have form yes because
shape and form are synonyms first of all
second a shadow does not have shape okay
that's an ordinary speech shape Shadow
why is it doesn't have shape because
it's light
we're talking about light and there if
you take the light away and you need
three objects actually the light the
object the tree and the shadow right but
you take the light and the tree away and
there is no Shadow okay and I want you
to do this experiment next time at home
okay uh always in the presence of a
relativist right because it's a
dangerous experiment
you take a flashlight right and a tree
or at night you know and you can create
an umbra or penumbra or whatever or you
can do it during the day you can have
the Sun or whatever you can have even a
very bright light right create a shadow
with some kind of object
then take the object and the light and
the source of light right to outer space
and tell me what kind of Shadow you see
out there okay and you'll see how the
shadow disappears it has no shape
whatsoever yeah all the Holograms um
Shadows
all those are um are not shapes okay
shape is what an object has all by
itself without the help of anything else
okay and I always give that analogy
where you have the angel with a little
plate or the ring on its head
without the Angel that's just a ring if
you want it to be a Halo you need the
angel
and therefore you can see the difference
between a ring or a plate on the one
hand and
a Halo on the other Halo requires the
angel without the angel all you have is
a plate for a ring
and it takes a long time for these
people to understand it because they
haven't gone through kindergarten
physics
okay let's get to the big bad hole
and we have to start again with the
scientific method okay here we start it
again so that we remind you what the
scientific method is compared to the
mathematical method here's the
mathematical method and what do they do
uh they observe do experiments they
measure visible objects because they
can't measure the invisible they
describe motion with equations propose
the most irrational explanation they can
imagine right using Concepts as
mediators as physical mediators and a uh
offer it to their colleagues to
challenge and confront their findings
whatever if more than 50 percent of them
agree with their Theory as it's called
in mathematics which is really a
description not a theory uh it becomes a
theory right the hunch becomes a theory
and when more than 90 percent of the
colleagues agree with a fellow not
because of a fact so in other words they
vote over there at the math club for
theories and if they have a lot of votes
then it becomes a fact and then you go
on a talk show uh talk circuit and win
prizes and so on what's the purpose of
this it's a persuade commence convert
and recruit people
we don't do any of that in physics okay
so I'm sorry to say to those people who
wanted to prove things and bring
evidence and so on we don't use evidence
in science
evidence is used to persuade experiments
are done so that you create evidence so
that you can persuade so we don't do
experiments either in science we have to
explain the cause uh the the result of
the experiment why it happened that way
that's what you got to do in physics
okay
okay so this is what we have for the
scientific method the real scientific
method here you have it uh three steps
hypothesis Theory and conclusions the
hypothesis is where what everybody skips
okay because you got to present the
objects and Mathematics uh
mathematicians and ith etheris and
electric universers and all these other
people all these dissidents and
mainstreamers they never present the
objects they never start by pointing to
the object that they're going to use uh
in their Theory and that's where we have
to start and of course you gotta also
have uh strong definitions that you
should be able to defend okay if you
can't defend your definitions your
definition is worthless uh so you got to
go back to the drawing board you can't
start your theory because you're you're
not at the Second Step yet you get
you're still on the first step and
um if you have a certain definition
that you can use consistently rationally
scientifically then it's valid and now
you can proceed to The Next Step which
is the statement of the facts right the
initial scene essentially okay you got
to start at frame number one of your
film okay we need to see what's in there
where you're what your starting point is
and now you can move on to step number
two which is the theory explaining your
theory okay you got to go through these
steps without them you have absolutely
nothing for sure you have an irrational
Theory okay because if you skip the
steps that you need to do the mandatory
steps what kind of theory do you have
yeah
okay so here's NASA NASA is a big uh
Power Player out there in the world of
so-called science okay so I mean NASA
doesn't know it who does
and uh this is what they're studying
this is these are the objects that they
present okay here it is okay and this is
out of their website and uh these are
the objects they put black holes Dark
Matter Dark Energy
um Big Bang the only one I didn't see in
there was wormholes but I'm sure if I
look strong enough uh you know a little
more time I'll find the wormholes in
there as well
so what are all these objects what what
are they talking about what are they I
mean this is what they're researching or
this is what they're spending their
money on you're I'm sorry your mind
they're spending your money on this okay
and so uh real quickly here you're
probably familiar with most of these
years the black hole okay looks
something like that okay swallows you
inwards okay we don't know what that is
but uh the first problem we've got there
is that you know there's really Zero
Dimensional that was proven by Mr uh
subramanyam chandrasekar uh in the 30s
and he got his Nobel Prize in 1984 for
proving that a black hole is Zero
Dimensional and a Hawking Stephen
Hawking talks about it in this book okay
so you can look that up and uh here's
the Wormhole looks something like this
essentially unites two universes as they
say okay there's a Universe on the
bottom in this scenario and another one
on the top and uh we can also have them
go in the opposite direction okay
so here it is going in the opposite
direction okay so you got them both ways
and we don't know what that is but they
call it a wormhole it's a hole through
space
okay so we have a hole through nothing
you know um
uh Bugs Bunny was a little smarter at
least he made it through the ground and
you can say the ground what's the ground
well the ground is all this Earth this
dust this you know what's underneath
your feet and so he made a hole in a
physical object which we call the ground
the hole is not a physical object the
hole is the absence of the physical
object in a sense right and these people
have a hole through nothing a hoe inside
a hole so I don't know how that works in
uh mathematical physics but that's what
they have with the
um with the wormhole here's the uh uh
Dark Matter okay you got a Galaxy and
you have all this blob that apparently
or allegedly right uh circles it and
keeps the stars from flying away
supposedly okay so this is more or less
the notion they have okay we don't know
what the blob is they never Illustrated
it really yeah but they put this blob
out there and they say that's Dark
Matter okay what is that stuff and they
say it's Mass
see and that's the issue the issue is
they go back to concept they say dark
matter is just a concept a mass lots of
mass heavy Mass
and what is that yeah so they
Illustrated well maybe putting little
dots and they sprinkle some salt and
they say well each one of these grains
of salt weighs tons and we'll call that
dark matter
what is that how come it's not in the
center of the Milky Way how come it's uh
it doesn't continue all the way to the
other Galaxy why isn't this dark matter
between the Earth and the moon which
would change gravity completely
I mean if a Grano that weighs tons and
tons and tons boy I hope they don't
bring one of those between the Earth and
the moon you know we'd be squashed
together suddenly you know the moon
against us that's what happens when you
just deal with Concepts such as mass and
say oh the mass did it you know you
haven't said anything I need a mechanism
how does these this uh Dark Matter let's
assume it's a bunch of particles because
that's what they think of they're
looking for the particle at the
accelerators so they're saying we're
going to produce we're going to discover
the particle known at the particle right
known as dark matter one of them okay
great so that means they think of
particles again and they think uh just
got a lot of mass great no problem
we'll concede all of that how does the
particle pull the star or push on the
star and prevent it from flying out of
the Milky Way why does it push it all
the way to the center of the Milky Way
what prevents all this force from
pushing it downwards and of course
they'll never answer that question
because they they just sprinkle that
stuff as needed ad hoc and they say look
it's all this blob that's preventing the
star from flying away and they need to
do it that way because they want to
explain in terms of mass
and it turns out that you know even with
mass you cannot explain why a star
doesn't fly out of the uh Milky Way or
or why uh Pluto doesn't fly out of the
solar system you can't do it with a word
mass what are you going to put some a
little dark matter particle there
preventing Pluto from flying out what's
preventing fluid Pluto from flying out
but preventing Jupiter and the Earth
from flying out of the solar system
that's what you got to figure out what
are you going to put space time
what time is that what you're going to
use you can't use warp time you can't
use field you can't use energy you can't
use dark matter or dark energy for that
matter which is pushing everything
outwards
so uh what are you going to put in there
we need a mechanism we need a we need to
see the object okay that's the first
step you don't have that you don't have
a theory all you have is a mathematical
description at best okay here's Dark
Energy pushing everything outwards
everything's flying in opposite
directions okay
okay great here's uh the other thing
that they're investigating which is Big
Bang you know explosion
and uh it becomes Dark Energy I guess
you know it's pushing everything
outwards after a while
okay so we have this is what they're
investigating
and uh using a lot of money to do so but
you see they hand out all this money to
a lot of phds or post-grads or whatever
and they're doing research on all this
stuff so all this money is going in that
direction okay that's that's the point
of today's lecture it's important to
understand what's happening to your
money what what they're producing with
this and what you're seeing is what
they're producing
and it's it's all holes it's all dark
it's all black you know I guess they're
racist because you know everything's so
nebulous you know and it's very heavy
you know black holes are heavy
um you know dark matter is heavy all
this stuff is very heavy it's invisible
it's intangible it's probably
translucent I don't know uh I guess uh
very heavy
there's lots of it it's all particles
heavy particles why the particle is so
heavy you know uh I mean why would one
particle be so heavy well they have to
make it heavy in order for their
equations to work otherwise their
equations don't work that's why the
particle is heavy it's it's the other
way around and uh you first present the
particle explain why it's heavy and then
you can do your your equations that's
how they do it they do it in reverse
okay
so here we have
um
all these things that they're
investigating okay the black hole the
Wormhole Big Bang dark matter and dark
energy this is what they have okay and
we should not forget space time here uh
it wasn't in their list but uh you know
space time is being investigated as well
okay
let me uh where did I put it
here it is
okay there's space time okay that's also
being investigated but uh you know this
is kid stuff now for them they they
looked at that in maybe their uh
freshman or sophomore year so they don't
deal with space-time as much as with the
other subject but yeah I remember
gravity Pro B proved that you know the
Earth drags time around itself so
sometimes they deal with space-time as
well
okay so here we have uh some of the
headlines that NASA put out so you can
see what came out of all your money okay
this is important here it is this is
what they're investigating this is these
are the uh news flashes that they put
out there and I just put the titles
there the headlines right uh help solve
black hole jet mystery okay unusually
close glimpse of black hole snacking on
Star Galaxy with black hole shines in
image from NASA's Chandra okay
astronomers dig out Berry black holes
with NASA's Chandra and so on
um telescopes capture Stellar delivery
service for Black Hole okay and that's a
Swift uh learns a new trick spots a
snacking black hole and uh Hubble finds
hungry black hole twisting captured uh
star into donut shade collapsing star
gives birth to black hole I think uh we
should have a birthday party this these
are the headlines it's all black hole
for black holes just alone for black
holes okay uh they have headlines for uh
not wormholes but or I haven't seen them
at least I haven't investigated that but
um they have them for all the other
stuff you know Dark Matter Dark Energy
Big Bang they're heavy on all that stuff
you know they're trying to approve all
this stuff to the public to justify
their funds and so this is what they're
researching and this is these are the
news flashes they put out constantly
it's always oh the black hole the
biggest black hole the farthest black
hole the newest black hole the greatest
the smallest you know they got all these
categories of black holes and all your
money is going in there supporting all
this nonsense and all they do is just
talk about these uh
objects they call them and here's the
NASA budget okay it's not uh cheap okay
uh 33 billion okay 33 billion I think I
could do something with all that money
that's coming out of your pocket okay
and that's uh what was it for this year
no 20 yeah this year 23. and you can see
that uh these people just use this money
for stuff like that it's not only for
black holes and all this uh nonsense of
no of holes and uh heavy inexistent
stuff and use it for other stuff as well
I'm sure they use this money to send
Rockets to the Moon all that stuff
that's good and the technology that's
also good no problem there but you know
there's a lot of money a lot of this
money is going to phds who sit down at a
desk and they theorize about black holes
and trying to break their heads uh about
different aspects of black holes and
meanwhile the astronomers look through
the telescopes you know now they have
the uh the web telescope out there and
they're trying to spot you know certain
clues that gives them an idea what uh
some of this stuff is black hole what
the dark matter is what the dark energy
is that's what they're looking for
okay here I have another organization
it's the National Science Foundation and
they have a budget of uh nine billion
almost 10 billion dollars okay and they
receive another billion uh in 2023
so what do they support well here's a an
example just one example and this is out
of Brazil okay and they say involving
the United States Canada Chile Brazil
Etc the Gemini Observatory is
international partnership to provide the
tools necessary to sustain cutting-edge
research input
the astronomical Sciences what do they
look for black holes Dark Matter Dark
Energy the same nonsense I just
discovered that I just discussed okay so
uh all these people are in the same boat
and this is maintained as you can see
down at about says National Science
Foundation so National Science
Foundation gives money to the Gemini
Observatory which is a um
a a group of people that are in
different countries with their own
telescopes their own computers their own
analysis and then they pull their
resources have meetings and they talk
about what Dark Matter Dark Energy black
holes wormholes space time Big Bang
that's where your money is going okay
and uh here's another famous country and
this is the uh United Kingdom and
they're spending uh says there
um what was it Point 48 almost 0.5 half
a percentage point of GDP so I looked up
GDP for Great Britain it's uh 784
billion and so if you take uh you know
half a percent of that approximately is
4 billion so they're spending 4 billion
on the Royal Astronomical Society what
do they do well they hand out all this
money so that people can research some
of these other things you know like
black hole dark matter all the same
nonsense that uh the NASA people in the
National Science Foundation are
investigating uh they do invest in
something else I thought I'd put the
point this out they're also into
diversity and inclusion so they have
lots of meetings on this this is very
important to spend your uh you know
British money on you know so they want
to make sure there's diversity inclusion
in uh the Royal Astronomical Society so
they spend more money on that than
researching even dark matter
okay here's uh the one in Germany okay
this is the max clunk Institute okay and
they're spending approximately two
billion euros okay so
um you know uh all these groups are
spending lots of money in the billions
and here that two billion dollars is
pretty much dedicated to Black Hole
almost all of it I'd say or the majority
of it because
um uh that's about all they do they do
dark matter and black holes wormholes
all this kind of stuff
okay so um uh just to rub it in I just
want to show you that if you do a Google
search you can do this on your own and
you look at the arctiv or the arcs War
okay and this is what you'll find uh for
black holes uh there's six million hits
or six million articles okay and there
you can see some of them regular black
hole a short topic review
uh one in a certain swirling Universe
Quantum wave Dark Matter okay rotating
Black Hole uh first law black hole and
so on okay so what do they do yeah
primordial black hole they found the
first one the last one the farthest one
the nearest one they found them all okay
or they're working on that and that's
what they write about
all these people receive funds from
organizations like the National Science
Foundation NASA you know all that money
trickles down
it's coming out of your pocket and going
to all these people doing this important
research okay I looked up wormholes it
wasn't as bad okay it's only uh what is
it uh about doesn't even get to two
hundred thousand it's a hundred and
hundred twenty thousand there okay and
so there you can see what they're
looking at traversable wormholes uh
that's very popular with all these guys
worm homes and time machines okay so
this is what they this what they
investigate okay and whether they have
charge or not
you know this is where your money's
going wormholes
it's all your money's falling down the
Wormhole to another Universe okay
because you'll never see it again
okay and uh this is what they're
investigating as far as dark matter and
um
I know this black holes okay uh same one
I just saw
but I had one for dark matter I guess I
missed it
okay and here's Dark Energy I hope this
one's Dark Energy okay I thought I'd
Point these out okay yeah Dark Energy
the rise of dark energy and multi-fuel
dark energy field theory of dark energy
and so on energy radiation early dark
energy and the late Dark Energy you get
there early in the late they got them
all so they're they're looking at dark
energy what is dark matter Dark Energy
what's pushing all the galaxies apart
you know so that we can explain why the
universe the universe is expanding hey
they call it the universe is a thing
they say okay so we don't know if it's
space that's expanding or or the planets
and stars or both you know
okay and here's the Big Bang also uh
what are the it's in the 700 000 not as
bad as black holes but you can see
there's a lot of that okay and again
they're all studying these things and
you can see how many papers or uh they
have written not not in this year I mean
but you can see there's a lot of
material out there uh talking about six
million uh papers or
websites or blogs talking about black
holes dark matter all this stuff talking
about millions and
um and yeah so it's these are popular
subjects that's what these people are
investigating that's how they justify
their money they go to Congress and they
say look we need more money this year
why uh what's going to happen well we're
researching black holes oh okay and
everybody heard about black holes oh
yeah that's important topic so they give
them money they give them another
million two billion or whatever no
problem and uh and what you're listening
is to you know all this being fed back
to you you know you put the money in and
you hear dark matter you hit black holes
you say I'm sick and tired of hearing
the first black hole the rotating black
hole the farthest black holder the
biggest the smallest you know uh is this
science
we found the first one we found the last
one we found the biggest the smallest
that we discovered is this just so that
guy can get a Nobel Prize or you know
get his paper published what is all this
about who cares about the biggest and
the smallest they don't know what
gravity is
they they can't explain uh you know they
cannot explain the simple thing how a
magnet attracts another
and they're working on black holes and
people say well how does a magnet
attract another why does the spoon fall
to the floor and they say oh we we
cannot explain that uh we'll never
explain we don't care
that's philosophy we're doing important
stuff we're working on black holes in
dark matter
and so yeah here's my conclusions okay
uh billions of dollars tax dollars right
uh dedicated to so-called scientific
research okay uh what is science
according to them math is
that's what it is mathematics and what
do they do uh equations plus irrational
explanations that's what they do and so
they work on equations uh descriptions
they call them theories okay all post
phds are working on or researching you
know black holes wormholes Dark Matter
Dark Energy Big Bang space time strings
they're working on this what is strings
black hole strings remember is a
holographic type of stuff that's what
they're working on you know the 2D is
mirrored on the 3D
uh when there is no 3D but they look at
the
Event Horizon 3D ball
even though there's nothing on the
inside of it because all matter has been
crushed out of existence there's not
even a singularity a singularity is just
the center of this concept
so you know that's what String Theory
investigates and so all these groups are
investigating with lots of money not
only government money but they're also
private funds there are lots of private
funds going to all these universities
all these think tanks out there
and uh yeah you can say a little private
money they can do whatever they want but
see the issue is that all this money is
going for what to be to present
uh nonsense stuff that doesn't exist
they're they're uh researching
inexistent things out there and that's
our world today and one of the answers
you get if uh you ask them you know uh
well what have you discovered of what is
gravity and what is we will never
understand how our universe works you
get these are the type of answers you
get father Universe does not have to
speak our language or we speak a
different language we'll never
understand him uh science is about
searching for truth but never finding we
just get more accurate what does
accuracy have to do with anything and
they say we get closer to the truth so
to speak you know because we're getting
ever more accurate uh Newton's equation
was pretty accurate but Einstein's a
little more accurate so we're getting
closer to the truth this has nothing to
do with accuracy it's got to do please
explain the mechanism we still don't
understand the mechanism you know of
gravity and they say we'll never find
out father Universe speaks a different
language and we're doing so we can only
get more accurate in what an equation
in measurements and physical
interpretations are anyways part of
philosophy they have nothing to do with
so-called physics you know so when you
ask for a physical interpretation they
give you an irrational answer irrational
interpretation why because they're going
to mediate it with Concepts You Know
Field uh energy ether you know and when
you uh Calder Bluff and say hey hold it
what are you trying to sell me you're
saying that a concept does all this and
we don't understand it either father
Universe speaks a different language and
anyways that is all philosophy